[Music]
thank you
foreign
programs here at Secrets unsealed and
some TV I'd like to know my name is CA
Murray and it is my privilege and
pleasure to welcome you to yet another
program as we open up and delve into the
word of God something we like to do
something we enjoy doing something we do
as often as we possibly can I'm in the
presence of two men of Distinction uh to
my right Pastor Daniel Miranda an
associate speaker here at Secrets
unsealed good to have you here Daniel as
always thank you it's good to be here
with both of you and our founder and
president and principal speaker at
Secrets unsealed some TV and that is
Pastor Stephen Moore Pastor as always
good to study the word of God with you
you don't know how much I enjoy this
program it's fantastic it's great to be
here it is a program that we enjoy first
of all it it moves us to study the word
of God it it it encourages us to do
something that we like to do uh and that
is share the word of God with you and
then it lets us know what's on your mind
what's in your heart uh as we speaks the
word of God so this is something we
really like to do now should you like to
get in on the fun you can do so very
easily you can send an email to TV at
some
tv.org that is TV at some
s-u-m-tv.org and we promise you we will
get to your questions just as soon as we
possibly can we have a fairly impressive
list of questions and we want to take do
deference and do time with each question
so we're not going to rush through
anything because we want to be thorough
in our answers so we're going to take as
much time as is necessary without taking
too much time but we will get to your
questions we promise we will get to them
sooner or later we also make you this
promise that we will come from the word
of God our answers will be based on the
word of God and the teachings of The
Seventh-Day Adventist Church if an
answer can be found in the word of God
we will find it in the word of God and
bring it to you that is the promise that
we make to you and we will do that on
each and every program Pastor Bohr if
you would open up with prayer then we'll
launch into our first question
Father in Heaven our wisdom is so
limited
we have just a little drop of knowledge
compared to what needs to be understood
and therefore we come before you to
plead for your presence we ask that you
will Enlighten our minds through your
scripture
we ask that you will bless those who are
watching that they might be blessed by
the answers as we find them in Scripture
we ask for your wisdom because we have
none
this we pray in the precious name of
Jesus amen amen thank you beautiful
prayer beautifully prayed thank you dear
Pastor our first question comes to us
from Roselle I will omit her last name
uh for now but uh this is from Roselle
she has uh three questions folded into
one and um she prefaces them by saying
that I like to know is very informative
and it's helpful for sincere people who
want to find biblical answers to their
questions for that we say hallelujah
amen and we agree with you uh the first
question deals with
um
why does God seem and I'm glad she put
the word seam in there to tolerate lying
she goes to F Exodus chapter 5 and verse
1 when Moses asked pharaoh to let Israel
go and hold a feast when in fact they
were actually leaving the land Daniel if
you will uh read Exodus 5 1 so he can
get some context and hear what the Bible
has to say yes I'm reading from the new
King James version it says afterward
Moses and Aaron went in and told Pharaoh
thus says the Lord God of Israel let my
people go that they may hold their feast
to me in the wilderness
probably be a good idea to read all the
way through verse 4. sure
verse 2 and Pharaoh said who is the Lord
that I should obey his voice to let
Israel go I do not know the Lord nor
will I let Israel go verse 3 so they
said the god of the Hebrews has met with
us please let us go three days journey
into the desert and sacrifice to the
Lord Our God lest he fall upon us with
pestilence or with the sword then the
king of Egypt said to them Moses and
Aaron why do you take the people from
their work
go back or get back to your labor
in verse 5 verse 5 and Pharaoh said look
the people of the land are many now and
you make them rest from their labor
all right I think that gives us the
context when you read all five verses
it's sort of unravels itself a little
bit and it becomes pretty clear that
their burden is not to go and leave but
to go and celebrate pastor and pastor
yeah it's interesting that we're in
verse 5 it says and Pharaoh said look
the people of the land are many now and
you make them Shabbat from their labor
that's an important word because the
spirit of Prophecy and Patriarchs and
Prophets tells us that when Moses
intended was to take them out into the
Wilderness to keep the Sabbath yes to
begin teaching them the observance of
the Sabbath because in their captivity
they had to a great degree forgotten how
to observe the sabbath or even to
observe the Sabbath and therefore
Pharaoh says oh you want to make them
Shabbat from their labors so now I'm
going to make it impossible for them to
shabbat so God I don't see God as lying
here through Moses you know actually it
simply says that Moses wanted to go to
the Wilderness for three days journey
yeah
and another important detail is that
Moses is not promising Aaron to come
back after three days
because he if he would say that then
that would sound like a lie yeah he's
saying I'm going to the Wilderness right
and worship and have a feast to the Lord
when you look at the context of of let
my people go on the call to to be let go
it might confuse one into thinking that
every request was was part of that
overall request but this was an
accommodation for a specific worship
experience that Moses was making of
pharaoh it wasn't he was okay let's get
on the Wilderness and we'll take off
yeah kind of thing no he was going to
worship and that was their burden and so
he was asking for that accommodation uh
uh of pharaoh right
good
alrighty have we have we dealt with that
one yeah there's a second example that
she also presents indeed Samuel and in
the case of Samuel in first Samuel 16 uh
when he anointed David the Lord told
Samuel that he will sacrifice to the
Lord but actually he is going to anoint
David all right so who's got first
Samuel 16 for me and I think we just
need just a few verses of that
particular chapter
I have it already
so let me read from verses one through
three
now the Lord said to Samuel how long
will you mourn for Saul
saying I have rejected him from reigning
over Israel feel your horn with oil and
go I am sending you to Jesse the
bethlehemite for I have provided myself
a king among his sons and Samuel said
how can I go if Saul hears it he will
kill me but the Lord said take a heifer
with you and say I have come to
sacrifice to the Lord so this is when
this is where they think that God is
encouraging him to lie verse 3
then invite Jesse to the sacrifice and I
will show you that you shall do
what you shall do you shall anoint for
me the one I name to you
all right Pastor what comes to your mind
what comes to my mind in simple terms is
two birds with one stone there you go
I've never I never have lik liked that
analogy because it involves killing
birds but but the expression simply
means that he does both things there's
no lie there
yep well said he offers sacrifices and
there is evidence for that yeah he does
offer sacrifice but at the same time he
anoints uh David yeah
do your sacrifice
then invite Jesse to the sacrifice so
you are literally the expression that
you don't like and I'm not that crazy
about it either but he's doing that and
so he's doing something else while he's
doing that so it's not a lie uh he is
going to sacrifice and and the the the
mechanism includes inviting Jesse and
family to to the sacrifice yeah Jesus
once said I have many things to say to
you but you can't handle them now yes
yeah so is he really hiding the truth no
what he's doing he's telling them what
they can assimilate up to that moment
and then he's going to reveal more so it
wasn't necessary for both things to be
mentioned just mentioning the sacrifice
would be enough yes and it would it
would have been premature for Samuel to
mention the anointment of David because
that would have stirred uh Saul's anger
and
um and affect God's plans in the
anointing of David maybe David wouldn't
wouldn't have lived
for him to take the Reign or the kingdom
in the following years if he found when
he found out later we saw how Saul
persecuted David imagine if he had found
out at this earlier stage there was
enough animosity already Yes they didn't
in other words didn't want to throw uh
fuel on the fire
and of course David wasn't chosen until
he came out and he said okay this is him
so we don't know precisely If he if he
knew exactly which one of those sons was
going to be anointed because he brought
out his big boys and then don't you have
anybody else I got this little kid yeah
you know but it can't be him we'll bring
him out yeah that's him and Samuel
Samuel didn't know right that it was the
youngest because when the youngest came
he what yeah you know he was kind of so
crippling yeah
yeah so again he he did take the heifer
so there was no lie you took the heifer
for sacrifice and so it follows through
so a good question insightful but uh we
are
so glad the Lord does not lie does not
cause his people to lie and we praise
the Lord for that amen amen all right
this next one will perhaps take the
remainder of our time together
um it is the most weighty perhaps of the
three
um I would like to ask what is the light
l-i-g-h-t that was created on the first
day of the week because the sun moon and
stars are yet to be created on the
fourth day
or well
I did an in-depth study of this
particular issue because it comes up
quite frequently in Q a sessions in
different places that I travel
the question itself has an issue when it
says because the sun moon and stars are
yet to be created on the fourth day the
Bible does not say that the sun moon and
stars were created the fourth day
the word is different it's the word made
and that's an important distinction the
bottom line is that the Sun
already existed the first day there's no
doubt whatsoever about that and I'd like
to share the information the reason why
Genesis 1 verses 3 through 5 Genesis 1
3-5 and there are several Expressions
here that I want us to notice five of
them to be more specific
this is describing the first day of
creation
then God said let there be light and
there was light
and God saw the light that it was good
and now comes the first expression I
want to dwell on and God divided the
light from the darkness
then verse 5 God called the light day
and the Darkness he called night so
there you have two which is day three
night
and then it says so the evening and
morning
that's the next expression number four
where the first day
so there's five points divide the light
from the darkness
called the light day called The Darkness
night
it was evening and morning and then the
day is given a number the first day
now
um when you when you go to
um
the fourth thing
you find that the same things are
mentioned for the fourth day
and you say how's that
well let's go back to Genesis chapter
where it speaks about the fourth day
Genesis chapter 1.
and let's read uh the account of the
fourth day to see if you have the same
elements as you have the first name it
says in verse 16.
and God made notice it doesn't say
created that's an important distinction
because the word created is the Hebrew
word Bara
which is never used of something that
man does
not once in the Old Testament is but I
used
as something that man does
the word that is used made is the word
ASA which is used very frequently in the
Old Testament to describe things that
man makes for example uh Noah made the
ark he did not create the ark he took
pre-existing materials he gave them
shape and formed the ark for a specific
purpose yes so it's us in other words
it's assembling the ark with
pre-existing materials so let's go back
to verse 16 then God made two great
lights the greater light to Rule the Day
in other words he's establishing the the
sun to Rule the Day and the Lesser light
to rule the night he made the Stars also
God set them in the firmament of the
Heavens to give light on the Earth
and to rule over the day and over the
night and now notice and to divide the
light from the darkness now wait a
minute didn't we read already that uh
that God divided the light from the
darkness on the first day The Identical
expression and then it says
um it continues saying and God saw that
it was good
so it was the evening and morning did we
find that the first day
yes what is it that marks the
distinction between evening and morning
it's the rising and setting of the sun
right I'm going to read a statement from
Ellen White and eventually that were
evening I think in the Hebrew means like
uh Sunset yes yeah so it doesn't have to
do with the sun and I actually have a
couple of uh a couple of quotations here
uh to that effect where it where it
speaks about uh the evening being the
moment when the sun sets yes so if it's
the moment when the sun sets how could
there be an evening and morning the
first day if there was no sun that's the
big question uh so then it continues
saying and God saw that it was good so
the evening and morning were the fourth
day once again the word day has a number
just like the first day as a number yes
now Ellen White has this very very
interesting statement that we find in
testimonies to ministers page 135
where she wrote God speaks to the Human
family in language they can comprehend
he does not leave the matter so
indefinite that human beings can handle
it according to their theories
when the Lord declares that he made the
world in six days that includes all six
days
not day four through day six it says
when when
the Lord declares that he made the world
in six days and rested on the seventh
day he means the day of 24 hours which
he has marked off by the rising and
Setting Sun yes
so did the sun exist the first three
days yes because he says all six days
were marked by the rising and setting of
the Sun so how do we resolve this issue
well I think the fourth day is simply
repeating what you have concerning the
first name
when it regards the Sun and the Moon
he's just confirming that the sun was
made to Rule the Day and the moon was
made to rule the night the the in other
words they were established for that
purpose he took them and he assembled
them so to speak to benefit the earth
now it's interesting that Ellen White
uh wrote that when Jesus comes a second
time
that the Heavenly
sun moon and stars are going to be moved
out of their places early writings page
41. yes they're going to be moved out of
the place that she says
and they're in the Millennium this world
is going to be in darkness as a result
and Jeremiah said that the Earth will
return to the condition it was in before
God began creation week he says that was
without form and void and the heavens
had no light why because the sun and
moon and stars were moved to where they
were before God placed them on the first
day and then confirmed on the fourth day
that they were made for the specific
purpose of establishing day and night
light and darkness so the fact that
Ellen White clearly states that all six
days
were marked we had an evening and
morning were marked off by the sun
indicates that the sun already exists
the first day so the light of the of the
first day was the light of the sun
um and it's interesting that
um you know for example when Adam and
Eve took the Fig leaves
and they assembled them to make aprons
of fig leaves the word Assad the same
word made yes so Bara means to create
primarily to create something from
nothing
which God did not was not indebted to
pre-existing matter according to
minister of healing 414 and 4 15. he's
spoken and existed yes but then God took
the pre-existing matter they had made
and he assembled the heavenly bodies so
that they could provide light and night
day and night uh evening and morning to
the planet
I think it's an excellent explanation
um they exist
in the first several verses and then
when you get to 16 it's like a
confirmation this is what this is for
it's there that's what it's going to be
it's going to be day this is what this
is for this is going to be nice and then
it adds for times and for Seasons yeah
Etc you know for yearly for yearly uh
measures of time yes for months you know
months the monthly uh you know the sun
establishes this day the moon
establishes the months and then for
times and Seasons the heavenly bodies
were established as well yeah and what
you said about the the sun me being
moved out of its place during the last
plagues that makes a lot of sense
because we understand that the last
place is a reversion of creation so if
there will be they will be moved out of
their places they will be dissembled uh
contrary to what happened in creation
right the sun was created in the first
day and then was assembled in the fourth
day with the with the with the stars and
the moon right so so so what is God
going to do when he creates a new
Heavens in the north what he's going to
do the fourth day well he's going to
take the sun moon and stars and he
replace them where they should be yes
and then there will be light and
darkness once again exactly day and
night evening and morning
amen well done well done and I hope that
was was clear because that is a question
that tends to repeat itself also uh as
time goes by it all right
um let's say I'm looking at my clock on
the wall maybe we can get through Lisa
um I'll try to read this as quickly as I
possibly can and then let you where
these have a shout at it hello I have
been listening to Pastor boss since
2020. when I finally woke up I was
raised on a very conservative in his
home but left the church for many years
since I have come back well I just well
it is just not the same church I
understand the importance of doing my
own research and study some of the
apostasy is hidden as well so well when
it comes to my attention
I am in disbelief I am unevenly yoked
and feel very alone sometimes unsure of
who to trust with the questions about
what is happening uh in the church and
in the world I read Ellen G white in the
Bible everything screams that this is
what Adventists have to be waiting for
why are we not talking and sharing about
the great controversy I see more
discussions and questions in the secular
Community about Liberty of conscience
being stomped on and resistant to
Conformity then I do some uh in those
who should be
rejoicing and declaring his uh he is
coming some comments I hear from
Juventus make me wonder when did
Adventist become too weak uh probably so
weak when did we start compromising with
our beliefs when did we allow ourselves
to become so deceived into complacency
reading and listening to my Bible in
Ellen White uh constantly is what keeps
me grounded but I have so many questions
and either uh yay that's nice next or
will be will will there will there are
topics that cause dissension and have no
real benefit so we should stay away from
those topics or just no interest at all
please do you have any guidance for me I
believe the Adventist message is the
truth but every time I see the apostasy
some so blatantly it breaks my heart I
just don't know who to trust anymore
yeah
yeah I I think we understand the sisters
situation
we are not blind to the condition of our
church
but I would say as a matter of counsel
that yes there is Apostles in the church
but
you should keep and looking to Jesus and
only Jesus because eventually or always
he is the only role model that we should
follow he's the only perfect one he will
never disappoint you or discourage you
um it's true and the good thing is that
we are not taken by surprise Jesus has
already said in Revelation uh speaking
of the laodicean church there is going
to be a lukewarm Church
it is very sad what we need to do is to
First leave out the truth for ourselves
and then in our sphere of influence
share that truth with love with
Christian love
and also with Clarity and being firm in
our convictions and and believe of the
truth you know what Lisa is saying
is not unique to her I get this
complaint Everywhere I Go
particularly from people who have left
the church
who left the church many many years ago
and then they come back
and they say wow
the emphasis of the church has totally
changed there's hardly anything about
Bible prophecy hardly ever is Ellen
White quoted in the worship service you
know the the worship service is Rowdy
hymns are no longer Sun I get that all
the time
and it's sad because because the
Adventist Church has a unique Heritage
yes it has a unique set of beliefs and a
unique lifestyle and only a person who
has left the church many many years ago
and come back can see the stock
difference you know it's kind of like
the frog and the cattle syndrome you
know when the frog is in the kettle uh
it can't uh it it can't discern the uh
that the heat is going up in the pot
until the frog is is actually boiled to
death and so people within the church
the change is so slow that they really
can't discern the change but those who
have been out and come back they can see
the DraStic change that has taken place
in the church yes the church
prior to the second of Christ is a
layout laodice institution yes it is it
is lazy and that and that's an
evangelism study of Prophecy uh
eschatology ecclesiology it's it's slack
but Christ is not going to come back for
a slack Church he's coming back for a
perfected bride so this what we see that
dominates the landscape now is going to
change praise the Lord amen and uh will
not be always the shaking
will take care
of the problems that the church has now
amen and amen well our time has fast
slipped into eternity allow me in
clothing to wish you both Grace and
peace through our Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ we'll see you again soon bye bye
and God bless
[Music]
foreign